SIMILAR WEBER NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE SURGEON
ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CLERK CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BRIAN BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRADE GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH. STONE
T. CALAVERAS BE APPROVED VIA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT YES WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN. IMAM
YASIR.
IN THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
I'M NOT A GUN. WE STAND BEFORE
YOU ASKING YOU THAT YOU BLESSED
US WITH ALL GOOD THAT EXISTS.
AND CONTINUE TO BLESS US WITH
SUCH. PROTECT US FROM ALL EVIL
BUT EXISTS TODAY AND KEEP US IN
YOUR PROTECTION. HELLO US TO
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP CONVICTION
IN YOU THAT YOU ARE THE SOURCE
OF PROTECTION. I MEAN. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AS HE LEADS
US IN THE PLEDGE. READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MAY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS IN THE
MINUTE SEVENTY ON THE AUTO
PASCHAL DONALDSON THE MEMBER
SERVICE RACES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS OF THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. STATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES TODAY
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN. THIS RAISE YOUR
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN TO HAVE
HER DAUGHTER SEATED AT HER DESK
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW THE SPEAKER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CARILLO AND
RUBIO TO SPEAK ON AN ADJOURN IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. FOR SO
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. SB SEVEN THIRTY
THREE WEST SO FROM THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE AND- SB
SEVEN SEVEN THREE ROTH FROM THE
RULES COMMITTEE TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THIS. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE TO HEAR SB EIGHT OH
FIVE RUBIO ON TUESDAY JUNE
TWENTY SECOND PENDING RECEIPT
FROM THE ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS TOURISM AND INTERNET
MEDIA COMMITTEE. MR FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THE RISE WE WITHHOLD
EMAILS CONSENT US ROLL CALL
VOTE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT
WE WILL MOVE TO A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE PROCEDURAL MOTION
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE MEMBERS AS THE PROCEDURAL
MOTION. MISS REYES IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISSED SOME
NUMBER FLOOR IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. LOCAL CLOSER ROLE IN HOW
THE VOTES IS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
TWELVE MOTION PASSES. SUMMARY
IS YOUR RECOGNIZE YOUR DIGITAL
DIGITAL PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM THIRTY ONE
SB EIGHT SIXTEEN SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND PLACED ON THE
INACTIVE FILE. LOCAL NOTE.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR
OBSERVANCE IN HONOR OF LGBTQ
PRIDE MONTH WITHOUT OBJECTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES WILL
PRESENT EACH R. FIFTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF HER FELLOW JOINT
AUTHORS CERVANTES ARE YOU READY
TO PROCEED WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY. THE CLERK WILL
READ. HOUSE RESOLUTION FIFTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER AND QUEER
PRIDE MONTH. THIS MODESTY ME
OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
LGBT Q. CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSE RESOLUTION FIFTY ONE.
WHICH RECOGNISES JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER AND QUEER
PRIDE MINE. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
PRIDE WAS INSPIRED BY THE
UPRISING AT THE STONEWALL INN
IN JUNE OF NINETEEN SIXTY NINE.
WHICH SPARKED A LIBERATION
MOVEMENT IN CELEBRATION OF
LGBTQ PLUS CULTURE. THIS CALL
TO ACTION CONTINUES TODAY AS WE
TRY TO LIVE UP TO OUR NATION'S
PROMISE OF EQUALITY LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. PRIDE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON THE
TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS OF
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY ARE TRY
AMPS ARE TRAILBLAZERS. WE HONOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE FOUGHT
BRAVELY AND CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR FULL EQUALITY. WHEN I THINK
OF PRIDE I THINK ABOUT BEING
THE FIRST OUT MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE. THE LEGISLATURE TO
GIVE BIRTH WHILE IN OFFICE
RIGHT TO ME IS SHOWING THAT MY
FAMILY OR LOVED OUR COMMUNITY
IS VALID AND IS WORTHY OF
EVERYTHING THAT WE DESIRE. AND
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT TWO WOMEN
CANNOT HAVE CHILDREN YOU SHOW
THEM THE TRUE POWER OF YOUR
LOVE BY HAVING THREE BABIES AT
ONCE. WELL INTENTIONED AND
VISIBILITY OF LGBTQ FAMILIES
THAT LOOK LIKE OURS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
CELEBRATE YOUR AROUND BUT EVEN
MORE DURING PRIDE MONTH. TO
THOSE THAT ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THEIR COMING OUT LOSING FAMILY
LOSING FRIENDS FEELING THE PAIN
THAT CAN COME WITH LIVING THEIR
LIFE AUTHENTICALLY. KNOW THAT
YOU ARE PRIDE. IN THE FIFTY TWO
YEAR SINCE THE STONEWALL RIOTS
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY HAS
ACHIEVED REMARKABLE PROGRESS
LANDMARK SUPREME COURT RULING
THAT STRUCK DOWN DISCRIMINATORY
LAWS IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
MARRIAGE EQUALITY BECAME THE
LAW OF THE LAND. AND WE HAVE
ESTABLISH WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS
FOR LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE IN MANY
STATES BUT THERE'S STILL SO
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE. ACROSS
THE COUNTRY STATE LEGISLATURES
ARE WAGING ATTACKS ON LGBTQ
RIGHTS PEOPLE STILL LACK
FUNDAMENTAL PROTECTION TO
HOSPITALS AND SCHOOLS AND THEY
ARE ON THE FACE. DROUGHT RISK
FACING DISCRIMINATION IN PUBLIC.
DURING THE PANDEMIC LGBTQ PLUS
INDIVIDUALS HAVE EXPERIENCE
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES OF
POVERTY AND INADEQUATE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE IN OUR NATION
CONTINUES TO WITNESS A TRAGIC
SPIKE IN VIOLENCE AGAINST
TRANSGENDER WOMEN. WOMEN OF
COLOR NO GENDER DIVERSE PEOPLE
EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA SOME
LOCAL CITIES HAVE DISPUTED ON
WHETHER TO FLY WIDE PRIDE A
PRIDE FLAG DURING THIS MONTH.
THESE ARE LOCAL CITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I'VE CALIFORNIANS
WE HAVE A DUTY TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST INTOLERANCE AND
CONTINUE OUR ROLES AS LEADERS
IN THE FIGHT FOR LGBTQ EQUALITY
QUALITY. IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST
DAY IN THE US TO LEGALIZE
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
SAME SEX COUPLES AND IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA
BECAME THE FIRST STATE IN THE
US TO OFFICIALLY BANNED THE USE
OF GAY PANIC AND TRANS GENDER
PANIC DEFENSE AND MURDER
TRIALS. AND IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN CALIFORNIA BECAME THE
FIRST STATE TO REQUIRE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO TEACH R. G. B. T. Q.
HISTORY TODAY WE RISE TO
CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY
AND LEADERSHIP ON LGBTQ
EQUALITY H. R. FIFTY ONE
AFFIRMS PRIDE MONTH AS A
CELEBRATION OF DIVERSITY
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISE OF
FULL EQUALITY. FOR LGBTQ
FAMILIES LIKE MY OWN. AS WE
FORMALLY RECOGNIZE PRIDE ON THE
FLOOR TODAY THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE I'LL GIVE YOU TO
KEEP CAUCUS HAVE PROVIDED EACH
OF YOU. WITH PRIDEFUL MEMENTOS
IN YOUR BAG INCLUDED. COLORLESS
SKITTLES TO SIGNIFY ONLY ONE
RAINBOW MATTERS THIS MONTH
HELLO PAL PEN. A FIRE TO HONOR
THIS YEAR'S PRIZE HONOREES WHO
WILL BE CELEBRATING DAYS THIS
WEEK AND EVERY DAY THIS MONTH
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE. MAY
YOU FIND PRIDE TODAY AND ALWAYS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BUILT ON HOUSE RESOLUTION FIFTY
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER MANTAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA YOUR
RECOGNIZING YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND
THE LET THE ANALYSTS AT THE
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR.
FIFTY ONE. AT THE TIME OF
CELEBRATION BUT ALSO A TIME TO
REFLECT ON THE TRIAL OF THE
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY AND THE
WORK WE STILL HAVE A HEAD. FELL
COMMITTEE QUEUE RIGHTS MOVING
WOULD BE NOWHERE WITHOUT THE
TIRELESS EFFORTS OF POWERFUL
AND RESILIENT CORRECTIVE ISSUE
FOUGHT AND CONTINUE TO FIGHT.
FOR PEOPLE'S FREEDOMS TWO X.
THIS. SOME OF THE CHAU BASE IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BRAVELY
FOUGHT FOR FULLY QUALITY
INCLUDE MARSHA P. JOHNSON A
BLACK SELF IDENTIFIED DRAG
QUEEN PROMINENT GAY LIBERATION
ACTIVIST. AND VETERAN OF
STALLONE RIOTS. STILL VERY VEDA
I LET THE NOW IDENTIFIED SIMPLY
AS CELIA INTER GENDER IDENTITY
REMAIN FLUID THROUGHOUT HER
LIFE. ANOTHER STONEWALL RIOTS
VETERAN SHE AND MARCIA FOUND
THE GROUP STAR STREET
TRANSVESTITE ACTION
REVOLUTIONARIES WHICH OFFERED
HOUSING TO HOMELESS IN TENTS IN
YOUR YOUTH IS PARTICULARLY
WONDERFUL POPULATION. WE ALSO
HAVE IS A MAJOR A BLACK
TRANSGENDER WOMAN SAY THAT
WHOSE HISTORY OF HOMELESSNESS
AND INCARCERATION TURNED HER
INTO ONE OF THE MOST ACTIVE
ORGANIZER'S. THE TRANS
COMMUNITY IN SAN FRANCISCO.
STORM THE LOVE VERY VERY EIGHT
THEY J. A RACIAL LESBIAN OFFER
ACTIVISM IN THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
AND FUNDRAISING FOR WOMEN
SEPARATE THE MASSIVE BALANCE
WITH THEIR CHILDREN. WE'LL SAY
WE'LL STUDY I LET THE AMERICAN
POLITICAL ACTIVIST A LONG TIME
TRACK FOR FORMER AND A VETERAN
WHO SERVED IN GERMANY DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. THREE BECAME THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY PERSON TO RUN.
FOR AGAME MEXICAN AMERICAN
FILMMAKER ARTIST AND GAY RIGHTS
AND HIV ACTIVIST THEN IS THE
LEóN A FORMER NEW YORK CIY
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSIONER WHO
IS ONE OF THE FIRST CITY
OFFICIALS TO ANNOUNCE THAT HE
WAS INFECTED WITH THE VIRUS
THAT CAUSES AIDS. AND WHO LATER
LED ONE OF THE NATION'S MOST
INFLUENTIAL ADVOCACY GROUP FOR
THAT THE ANALYST WITH AIDS.
SALLY IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
WITNESSED A HORRIFIC SPIKE IN
FATAL VIOLENCE AGAINST
TRANSGENDER WOMAN OF COLOR AND
UNDER. GENDER DIVERSE PEOPLE.
SOCIAL IDENTITIES MATTER
THEY'RE NOT INTANGIBLE CONCEPT
THAT WE SHOULD SHY AWAY FROM
AMPLICON REYES STATIONS. AS A
SOCIETY WE MUST DO A BETTER JOB
OF CREATING SPACES FOR PEOPLE
TO BE FULLY EXPRESSIVE OF WITH
THEY ARE. INTO A KNOWLEDGE SO
MANY LAYERS THAT WE COMMON OUT
THERE AND I INTERSECTION
MALADIES. BEING THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY AS A SINGLE
HOMOGENEOUS COMMUNITY CAN BE
DETRIMENTAL. NOT RECOGNIZING
THAT ADVERSITY WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY AFFAIRS THE VOICES OF
LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCE DEPRESSION DUE TO
INTERSECTION IDENTITIES. I THE
WHOLE US POPULATIONS EXPERIENCE
AN INCREASED RISK OF
UNEMPLOYMENT HOMELESSNESS FOOD
INSECURITY THERE IS ONLY
ELEVATED FOR THE LGBTQ PLUS
PEOPLE PEOPLE WILL ALSO FACE
REJECTION FROM FAMILIES AT
HIGHER RATES AND HAVE LESS
SUPPORT NETWORK ON WHICH THEY
CAN RELY ON IT TENS OF HELD A
FINANCIAL CRISIS. THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION ROLL BACK
SEVERAL POLICIES PROTECTING
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE FROM
DISCRIMINATION IN HEALTH CARE
AND IN HOMELESS SHELTERS WHICH
MANY PEOPLE ARE. LIKELY TO NEED
IN THE WAKE OF COVER NINETEEN.
I MONTH THIS PLAN ONCE WE WILL
CELEBRATE WILL ALSO MUST
CONTINUE TO FIGHT IN HONOR OF
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY BY UNITING
OUR ADVOCACY EFFORTS UNDER ONE
INTERSECTIONAL UMBRELLA HELPING
TO ENSURE THAT NO ONE FALLS
THROUGH THE CRACKS OF THESE
MOVEMENTS. AND ALSO SHERRY
STONER WITH A TALKING TO A
COUPLE OF MY FRIENDS. I'LL LET
YOU KNOW GAYS AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE TALK ABOUT OUR
LATINO IDENTITIES WE DON'T
ALWAYS LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
CREDIT ENTITY AT THE SCENE
SPACE. AND HOW WE KEEP DISTINCT
OR SEPARATE ONLY TALKED ABOUT
HOW DO WE ARE SET TOGETHER
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT WE
DON'T NEED THOSE IDENTITIES
BEHIND WE WALK INTO THE INTO. A
LATINO GROUP OR INTO A CAREER
GROUP OUT THERE AND SO I JUST
TALKED TO THE WORK THAT WE
STILL HAVE TO DO OUT THERE AS
WE- NAVIGATE THE SPACE SOME OF
THE DISCUSSION. BOARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JIM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED LEADERS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO RISE ON BEHALF OF OUR
API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. PRIDE
MONTH IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
MONTHS OF THE YEAR. IT'S A
MONTH WHERE MY CITY BECOMES
ALIVE. ACTUALLY EVEN LIVELIER
THAN IT USUALLY IS IT'S A TIME
WHEN WE CELEBRATE LOVE EVERY
SINGLE DAY OF THE YEAR. IT'S
BEEN A STRUGGLE AT TIMES- IN
OUR CITY OUR CITY HAS
CONSTANTLY EVOLVING AS PEOPLE
HAVE COME AND GONE. WITHIN OUR
CITIES COMMUNITY FABRIC. BEFORE
OUR LGBT COMMUNITY THIS IS BEEN
AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE I THINK
BACK TO THE TIME WHEN I WAS OUR
COUNTY'S ASSESSOR RECORDER AND
I NEVER THOUGHT THAT BEING THE
PERSON WHO SIGNS MARRIAGE
LICENSES WOULD EVER BE A
CONTROVERSIAL THING EVER. IN
POLITICS. BUT THERE WE WERE AS
OUR COMMUNITY WAS TRY
STRUGGLING TO FIGHT FOR
MARRIAGE EQUALITY. AND OUR CITY
WAS SO PROUD TO REALLY BE AT
THE FOREFRONT. OF THAT EFFORT
TO FOCUS AND TO TALK ABOUT
FAMILIES WANTED TO BECOME
UNITED. AND I REMEMBER. I HAD
THE HUGE HONOR OF MARYLAND ONE
COUPLE WHEN. GAY MARRIAGE FIRST
BECAME LEGAL AND IT WAS A
CAUCASIAN MALE AN ASIAN AND
ASIAN MALE WHO I MARRIED IN MY
OFFICE. AND I REMEMBER HIS
CHINESE MOTHER COMING UP TO ME
AFTERWARDS. AND SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR MAKING OUR FAMILY
HOLE. IT WASN'T THAT. THE MOM
DID NOT THINK OF HER FAMILY'S
WHOLE. IT WAS SOCIETY'S
PROBLEMS HE WAS OUR PROBLEM
THAT WE HAD ALWAYS MADE THIS AN
ISSUE THEY HAVE LONG ACCEPTED
THIS FAMILY AS PART OF THEIR
FAMILY. BUT REMOVING THIS FINAL
PART OF STIGMA REMOVING THIS
LEGAL BARRIER SOMETHING THAT
WAS SO IMPORTANT TO HER THIS
THIS OLDER IMMIGRANT CHINESE
WOMAN. AND SO I THINK ABOUT ALL
THE OTHER APR IS WHO ARE LGBTQ.
AND THEIR STRUGGLE AS THEY HAD
TO COME OUT TO THEIR FAMILIES
AND HOW DO. DEAL WITH THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT I KNOW OUR COMMUNITY HAS
REALLY. GROWN ON IT HAS REALLY
EVOLVED ON I REMEMBER WHEN WE
WERE TOUGH FIGHTING- THE
NONPROFIT CAMPAIGN AND TALKING
ABOUT. HOW WE COULD MESSAGE
THIS ISSUE IN OUR PARTICULAR
API COMMUNE. IT TO ME IT ALWAYS
CAME BACK TO THE FOCUS ON
FAMILY. BECAUSE FAMILY IS SUCH
A CENTRAL PART OF OUR COMMUNITY
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
AND FOR US THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT. FAMILIES BEING ABLE TO
COME TOGETHER. BE ABLE TO LIVE
TOGETHER AND TO BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE WHO THEY LOVE. TOGETHER
AND ULTIMATELY WAS THE WINNING
MESSAGE AND IF YOU LOOK AT
WHERE OUR COMMUNITY HAS COME
EVEN IN THE LAST FIFTEEN TWENTY
YEARS. IT'S REALLY MIRRORS THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY BUT IN MANY
WAYS IT MIRRORS THAT EXACT
THOUGHT PROCESS ONCE THEY
REALIZED. THAT THIS WAS ABOUT
PROTECTING THEIR FAMILY ABOUT
CHOICE FOR THEIR FAMILY IT IS
ABOUT. LOVE LOVING THEIR
FAMILY. ALL THE OTHER ISSUES
DIDN'T SEEM VERY IMPORTANT. AND
SO FOR THAT I RISE AND ASK ALL
OF US TO SUPPORT HR FIFTY ONE
THE TO CELEBRATE PRIDE MONTH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR TANG.
AS A MEMBER ARAMBULA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED YOUR DESK. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT I COME FROM THE
CITY OF FRESNO AND YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD ME TALK ABOUT THE ZIP
CODE THAT I COME FROM AS WELL
NINE THREE SEVEN TWO EIGHT. IT
IS IN THAT ZIP CODE THAT I GREW
UP AND HAVE THE HONOR OF LIVING
RIGHT NOW IN THE AREA OF FRESNO
CALLED THE TOWER DISTRICT AN
AREA THAT FOR DECADES HAS BEEN
ACCEPTING WELCOMING AND LOVING
TO OUR LGBT COMMUNITY IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND IT IS
IN THAT TOWER DISTRICT THAT WE
HAVE A THEATRE A THEATRE THAT
HAS A REAL PRIDE FILM FESTIVAL
EVERY YEAR DOCUMENTING AND
SHOWING LGBTQ FILMS A FILM
FESTIVAL THAT MY SISTER IN LAW
WHO'S MARRIED TO MY SISTER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND IS A
HIGHLIGHT IN OUR COMMUNITY. BUT
IT WAS JUST THIS YEAR IN THE
CITY OF FRESNO THAT WE FOR THE
FIRST TIME RAISED THE PRIDE
FLAG IN OUR COMMUNITY AND SO
YOU MUST IMAGINE THE EXUBERANCE
I HAPPEN TO ME SEE MY SISTER ON
LAW OUT THERE GIVING A SPEECH
TALKING ABOUT WHAT IT MEANT FOR
HER IN OUR COMMUNITY TO SEE
THAT FLAG RAISED IN FRESNO. AND
YOU MUST UNDERSTAND THE JOY
THAT CAME OUT FROM SO MANY IN
OUR COMMUNITY BUT THE STRUGGLE
IS REAL AS WELL BECAUSE THERE
WAS A YOUNG CITY COUNCILWOMAN
JUST SOUTH OF FRESNO IN A CITY
CALLED KINGSBURG JUL HER TADO
WHO TRIED TO DO THE SAME THING
TO HAVE PRIDE CELEBRATED IN
THAT CITY. AND SHE BROUGHT THIS
UP AND WAS A TAPPED WHILE ON
THE DYESS SHE WAS UNSUCCESSFUL
IN HER ABILITY TO RAISE THE
FLAG IN THAT CITY BUT WE MUST
NOT FORGET THE STRUGGLE IS REAL
FOR SO MANY TO SEEK THAT
ACCEPTANCE THAT WE MUST
HIGHLIGHT WHEN WE DO MAKE
PROGRESS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO STRIVE TO MAKE
PLACES IN THE VALLEY. REFLECT
THE VALUES OF OUR GREAT STATE
SO WHILE MANY OF YOU ARE GOING
TO VOTE TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU AS WELL TO BE ADVOCATING
AND FIGHTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE IN YOUR
BACKYARD. AND YOUR COMMUNITIES
AS WELL. I THANK YOU AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR HR FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU DR ROBERT LEFT.
SENATE AROMAS YOUR RECOGNIZING
HER DESK. THANK YOU OF THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF HR FIFTY ONE IT
IS CRITICAL THAT NO ONE BE MADE
TO FEEL LESS THAN BECAUSE OF
RACE COLOR CREED ARE WHOM ONE
LOVES. THE NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE STAND WITH OUR LGBTQ
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND AFFIRM
YOUR RIGHTS TO LIVE FREE OF
PERSECUTION. IT IS PAST TIME
FOR US TO NOT ONLY LEARN TO
RESPECT AND HONOR ONE ANOTHER
BUT TO ACTUALLY PRACTICE
RESPECT AND ELIMINATE PREJUDICE.
I JOIN THE AUTHOR AND MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN RECOGNIZING
JUNE AS LGBT Q. MONTH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS BUT
WE CAN'T JUST CELEBRATE ONE
MONTH OUT OF THE YEAR WE HAVE
TO CELEBRATE ALL THE MONTHS OF
THE YEAR EVERY MINUTE. BECAUSE
EVEN OUR LOVE ONES THAT WE
HAVE. THE LOVED ONES THAT WE
HAVE THAT ARE STILL OUT THERE
THAT ARE COMING OUT RIGHT NOW
TODAY WE NEED TO SHOW THEM LOVE
WE NEED TO SHAUN WELCOMING WE
NEED TO BE OPEN AND SHOW THAT
LOVE THIS SO MANY HAS SHOWN US.
IT'S A BRUSH SPREADING THAT
LOVE INTO OUR COMMUNITY AND
SPREADING THAT ACCEPTANCE OF
ONE ANOTHER THE ONLY TRULY TALK
ABOUT STANDING UNITED THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL PEOPLE
IN ALL WAYS OF LIFE THAT WE
STAND UNITED AND I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ON HR FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU MR ROLLINS. DECEMBER
BLOOM YOUR RECOGNIZED YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR FIFTY
ONE THE JEWISH CAUCUS IS
PLEASED TO JOIN WITH
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL FAITHS AND
BACKGROUNDS AND CELEBRATING
PRIDE MONTH. WHICH IS A SPECIAL
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE THE REMARKABLE
CULTURE ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LGBTQ PLUS
CALIFORNIANS OF COURSE I'M
PROUD TO REPRESENT THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD ONE OF THE
LARGEST AND MOST VIBRANT LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
HISTORIC. PART OF THE MOVEMENT
FOR LGBTQ RIGHTS PRIDE MONTH
ALSO GIVES US A SPECIAL
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LGBTQ JEWS WHO
ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE FABRIC OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE JEWISH
COMMUNITY. THIS MONTH MANY
SYNAGOGUES ACROSS THE STATE
WILL CELEBRATE PRIDE MONTH BY
HONORING LGBTQ COMMUNITY THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AT FRIDAY NIGHT
SERVICES. AND WE'RE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY'S LEADERSHIP
AND MANY PROMINENT JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS. INCLUDING RABBIS
CANTORS AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS
OF MAJOR INSTITUTIONS. AND THIS
WOULD INCLUDE BETH HI AM HOW
DOES SHE CAME RIGHT IN MY
DISTRICT. FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO AS THE WORLD'S
FIRST SYNAGOGUE BY AND FOR GAY
AND LESBIAN JEWS IN THE WORLD.
WE ALSO TAKE SPECIAL PRIDE IN
THE MANY CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
LGBTQ JEWS HAVE MADE TO OUR
STATE AND NATION IN SO MANY
FIELDS INCLUDING ART LITERATURE
SCIENCE BUSINESS ENTERTAINMENT
AND MEDIA. WE APPLAUD LGBTQ
JEWS WHO HAVE HELPED TO LEAD
THE FIGHT FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
REPUBLIC SERVICE BEGINNING WITH
HARVEY MILK WHO BOLDLY PAVE THE
WAY FOR OTHERS. OTHERS
INCLUDING CONGRESSMAN FORMER
CONGRESSMAN BARNEY FRANK
COLORADO GOVERNOR JEROD PAULUS
THE FIRST OPENLY TRANSGENDER
MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE BARBARA
KASPAR SUPERSPEED AND THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON. BUT COLLEAGUES
WE ALSO SOLEMNLY AND
SIMULTANEOUSLY MARK THE FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE PULSE
NIGHTCLUB MASSACRE THIS JUNE.
THE DEADLIEST ATTACK ON THE
LGBT COMMUNITY IN AMERICAN
HISTORY AND WE MUST RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS STILL MUCH MUCH
MORE WORK TO BE DONE TO ADVANCE
THE RIGHTS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND WHILE THE SHOOTER AT THE
PULSE MAY NOT HAVE SPECIFICALLY
BEEN TARGETING. THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY THE ATTACK WAS
MOTIVATED BY HATE AND VENGEANCE
AND THE COMMUNITY BECAME THE
VICTIM AS IS. TOO FAR OFF IN
THE CASE. TWENTY TWENTY WAS
RECORDED BY THE HUMAN RIGHTS
CAMPAIGN AS THE MOST VIOLENT
YEAR AGAINST TRANSGENDER AND
GENDER NONCONFORMING PEOPLE.
SINCE THEY BEGAN TRACKING SUCH
HATE CRIMES WITH FORTY FOUR
FATALITIES RECORDED. HRC IS
ALSO COUNTED OVER ONE HUNDRED
BILLS INTRODUCED THIS YEAR
ALONE TO CURB THE RIGHTS OF THE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LAPD HAS
REPORTED A 66% INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES OVERALL AND A 26%
INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES BASED
ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION. WE MUST
DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
ENSURE EQUALITY FOR EVERYONE
AND THAT NO ONE FEARS FOR THEIR
SAFETY OR THEIR LIVES BECAUSE
OF THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
THERE'S STILL SO MUCH TO BE
DONE BUT THERE'S HOPE AND THE
JEWISH CAUCUS WILL STAND STRONG
AND PROUD WITH THE L. G. B. T.
Q. KAKAK CAUCUS AS WE KEEP
FIGHTING FOR EQUALITY. AND
WHAT'S RIGHT. AND FINALLY
HERE'S HOPING THAT WE CAN ALL
ATTEND PRIDE PARADES NEXT YEAR.
AND CELEBRATE THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND SUITABLE FASHION
BECAUSE YOU JUST CAN'T DO IT
JUSTICE ON ZOOM. AND SO ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON HR FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM. DECEMBER WEBER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZING YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR FIFTY
ONE. PRIDE MONTH IS A TIME WHEN
WE COME TOGETHER TO RECOGNIZE
THE VALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY ALL OVER
THE WORLD. IT IS A TIME FOR
THE CONTINUOUS FIGHT FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS FOR ALL. I STAND PROUD
SUPPORT OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
AND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
ONGOING STRUGGLE AGAINST ANY
FORM OF DISCRIMINATION OR
INJUSTICE. LAST THURSDAY OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
ADVANCEMENT OF THE LGBTQ
EQUALITY SPACE HAVE OCCURRED AS
A DIRECT RESULT OF THE WORK OF
BLACK LGBTQ ACTIVIST. THERE IS
A LONG LIST OF BLACK LGBTQ
LEADERS WHO STOOD AND CONTINUE
TO STAND AT THE FOREFRONT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ADVANCEMENT OF
HUMAN AND CIVIL RIGHTS FOR ALL
AMERICANS. MANY OF THEIR NAMES
HAVE BEEN STATED ON THIS FLOOR.
BUT OTHERS HAVE NOT SUCH AS
BAYNARD RUSTIN. BILL WILSON
LAVERNE **** ANDREA JENKINS
LORI LIGHTFOOT AND OFF FUNDS-
DAVID TO NAME A FEW. OVER THE
YEARS THESE EXTRAORDINARY
ACTIVISTS FROM THE BLACK LGBTQ
COMMUNITY HAVE MOVED US WITH
THEIR TALENT COURAGE STRENGTH
AND LEADERSHIP. FROM ADVOCATING
pICONIC BLACK ART THE BLACK
LGBTQ COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO
LEAD IN THE SPACE OF RADICAL
CHANGE AND POLITICS. BUT
DESPITE THESE AMAZING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THESE LEADERS
AND THE LGBTQ MOVEMENT. BAR TO
MANY MEMBERS OF THE BLACK LGBTQ
COMMUNITY REMAIN MARGINALIZED
AND FACE DISPROPORTIONATE
DISCRIMINATION VIOLENCE AND
OTHER FORMS OF PERSECUTION
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN AND WHO THEY CHOOSE TO
LIVE. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN HIGHER
RATES OF SUICIDE ATTEMPTS AND
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND BLACK
LGBTQ YOUTH AND ADULTS WHEN
COMPARED TO OTHER GROUPS. AND
IN TWENTY TWENTY OVER FORTY
FOUR TRANSGENDER OR GENDER
NONCONFORMING PEOPLE WERE
FATALLY SHOT OR KILLED BY
VIOLENT MEANS. THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH WERE BLACK OR LATIN ACTS.
SO AS WE CELEBRATE AND REFLECT
ON THE HISTORIC CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY. I
URGE YOU TO ALSO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE MULTIPLE INTERSECTING
STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES FACED BY
BLACK LGBTQ COMMUNITY DUE TO
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY AND RACIAL IDENTITY.
WE MUST ALL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOWARDS THE ADVANCEMENT OF
EQUALITY FOR ALL PEOPLE
INCLUDING THOSE WHO STILL
STRUGGLE TO ATTAIN THE BASIC
RIGHTS THAT ALL SHOULD BE
AFFORDED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON HR FIFTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR
EVER AS A MEMBER JONES SAWYER
YOU RECOGNIZE YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OR HR
FIFTY ONE. I MONTH IS A SPECIAL
TIME FOR ME AND MY FAMILY. A
TIME OF HIGHLIGHTING AND
CELEBRATING LAW. I RECOGNIZE IN
OUR COUNTLESS BROTHERS SISTERS
AND SIBLINGS ARE OFTEN CAST
INTO DEBATES ABOUT WHO THEY
SHOULD BE. VERSUS WHO THEY ARE.
AS SOME OF YOU KNOW. SOME OF
YOU DON'T KNOW. REGINALD BYRON
JONES SAWYER JUNIOR IS GAY.
THAT'S MY SON. AND AS HIS
FATHER I HAD THE DISTINCT HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE OF OFFICIATING MY
OWN SON'S MARRIAGE TO IS NOW
HUSBAND IN A MOVING CEREMONY
FILLED WITH UNCONDITIONAL LOVE
AND SUPPORT. WHEN MY SON CAME
OUT TO ME. HE THOUGHT I WOULD
BE ANGRY. AND TO THIS DAY I'M
ANGRY BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
I DID. TO GIVE HIM THAT IN
SECURITY THAT HE COULDN'T TELL
ME ABOUT THE MOST INTIMATE
THING ABOUT HIM. THAT'S WHEN I
REALIZED. AS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY WE STILL
HAVE A LONG LONG WAY TO GO.
BEFORE MARRIAGE EQUALITY WAS
ACHIEVED THE ONLY OPTION FOR
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MY SON WAS SUB
STANDARD DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
THESE PARTNERSHIPS FOR CITED AS
QUOTE UNQUOTE MIDDLE GROUND THE
SEPARATE BUT EQUAL. OPTION FOR
SAME SEX COUPLES THE SAME
RHETORIC THEY USED TO KEEP
SEGREGATED SCHOOLS IN PLACE.
COMPROMISES BOTH SHOULD NOT AND
CANNOT BE MADE FOR INDIVIDUALS
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS. REALLY
THERE IS NO MIDDLE GROUND.
HONORING THE LGBTQ PRIDE
MOVEMENT WE MUST ALWAYS PAY
TRIBUTE TO THOSE BRAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO IGNITED THE
MOVEMENT AND ALWAYS REMEMBER
THAT IT WAS SPEARHEADED BY
CLEAR PEOPLE OF COLOR
ESPECIALLY TRANSGENDER
INDIVIDUALS. THROUGHOUT THE
MOVEMENT CLEAR BLACK ORGANIZED
HAVE STOOD FIRM IN THEIR
INTERSECTIONAL IDENTITIES AS
THEY HAVE LED TO SEEK TRUE
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE AND AS THE
MOVEMENT CONTINUES IN HIS
PERSEVERANCE STILL TO THIS DAY
WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT QUEER
BLACK INDIVIDUALS HAVE LONG
BEEN OVERLOOKED. AND EVEN THE
RACE FROM THE NARRATIVE WHEN
DISCUSSING THE PROGRESS THAT
HAS BEEN MADE FURTHER DURING A
PERIOD OF HEIGHTENED
DISCRIMINATION AND ABUSES
AGAINST AYE TRANSGENDERS.
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ESPECIALLY
THOSE OF COLOR IS EVIDENT THAT
THERE IS STILL WORK TO BE DONE.
WE MUST HAVE AN EQUIVOCAL. BUT
WE MUST UNEQUIVOCALLY AFFIRMED
THE TRANSGENDER LIVES MATTER
BLACK TRANS LIVES MATTER AS WE
CONTINUE FIGHTING AGAINST
UNJUST HATE AND ABUSE AGAINST
THE L. G. B. T. Q. COMMUNITY
YOU MUST ALL UNDERSTAND THE
HISTORY OF THE STRUGGLE. I NOT
IT THOSE WHO WERE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF AFFECTING POSITIVE
CHANGE. DURING MY COLLEAGUES OF
THE L. G. B. T. Q. LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO CELEBRATE LOVE AND
ONE'S IDENTITY WE MUST
RECOGNIZE EARNS ARE INSEPARABLE
INTERSECTION MALADY AND
CONTINUE TO WORK IN UNION AS WE
SEEK TO PROMOTE TRUE EQUALITY.
AND JUSTICE. END TO END. AS A
PROUD FATHER OF A GAY MAN THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
UNANIMOUS UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR
HR. FIFTY ONE. NAME IS A JONES
SAWYER. SEVERALLY YOU'RE
RECOGNIZING YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU AS A SPEAKER HAPPY PRIDE
MONTH MEMBERS I'M VERY HONORED
TO BE JOINING YOU ON
CELEBRATING PRIDE MONTH HERE AT
THE STATE CAPITOL WHERE OF
COURSE THE ONLY PERHAPS ONLY A
FEW DECADES AGO THIS WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN IMAGINABLE THE
PROGRESS REMAINS A SOCIETY TO
TAKE DECADES AGO WOULD NOT BEEN
IMAGINABLE I DO WANT ALSO THANK
MY MANY COLLEAGUES FROM ACROSS
THE STATE THAT REMINDED US THAT
BEING LGBTQ PLUS PART THE
COMMUNITY IS BY DEFINITION.
INTERSECTIONAL EVERY MEMBER OF
THOSE UV PLUS COMMUNITY
OBVIOUSLY HAS A RACE AGE GENDER
RELIGION AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
SITTING AT THIS CROSSROADS OF
INTERSECTION HOW IMPORTANT IS
TO BE UP LIFTING THE
COMMUNITIES OF CONSOLATION
RUBBLE FROM OPPRESSION IN THIS
COUNTRY WHETHER. IT BE YOUR
ETHNIC GROUP OR RELIGIOUS GROUP
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT REMINDS
ME OF AMONG OUR FANTASTIC TEN
HONOREES ARE HONORING TODAY I
HAVE TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT TO KIM TRAN WHO I'VE
HONORED WHO IS FROM MY HOMETOWN
OF SAN JOSE WHO HAS FOR OVER A
DECADE. FOCUS ON HER WORK IN
FACILITATING ANTI OPPRESSION
TRANS INCLUSION AND OPERATING
ANTI BLACK THE STRINGS FOR A
WIDE ARRAY OF AUDIENCES
INCLUDING THE U. S. CONSULATE
AND IS ALSO INSTRUCTIVE
INFORMED LGBT LGBTQ YOUTH SPACE
IN SAN JOSE WHICH IS A
THERAPEUTIC SAY SPACE A QUEER
YOUTH IN THE SOUTH BAY. AND I
HIGHLIGHT THAT BECAUSE I THINK
SOMETHING THAT IS REALLY RUDE
ESPECIALLY TODAY AND ACTIVISM
OF QUERY ACTIVISTS IS THAT
WITHOUT HAVING TOTAL LIBERATION
FOR ALL PEOPLE AND IN THIS
COUNTRY IN THIS WORLD ACTUALLY
WE CANNOT HAVE QUEER LIBERATION
AND THAT'S WHAT WE KANTANA
FRONT LINES FIGHTING WITH EVERY
SINGLE OTHER GROUP. AND
SOMETHING THAT REMINDS ME IS
THAT HOW IMPORTANT THE POWER
PRESENTATION REALLY IS I THINK
ABOUT IN THE LGBT CAUCUS RIGHT
NOW SENATOR LAYERED WAS ONE THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY MAYOR IS IN
ALL OF THE COUNTRY I BELIEVE
AND HOW THAT PROGRESSES
PERCOLATE UP TO THE POINT WHERE
I CAN STAND HERE DO YOU AS WELL
THE YOUNGEST EMBERS ALSO THE
FIRST BISEXUAL SAY LEGISLATOR-
IT IS AN HONOR AND A
RESPONSIBILITY I DO NOT THINK I
WAS I CERTAINLY GOING TO HAVE
AND I WAS LIKE I THOUGHT
THERE'S ACTUALLY SOMEONE ELSE
THAT WAS OPENLY BISEXUAL FOR
ME. BUT IN CONVERSATIONS OF MY
COMMUNITY. I'M REMINDED THAT
THE L. G. B. HE PLUS COMMITTEE
I TOLD YOU PLUS. LGB APPLE PLUS
ACRONYM THEY MUST BE ABLE AKRAM
IS ACTION THE PLUS. PLUS
INDICATING THAT WE SHOULD
ALWAYS TRY TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE
AND ADDING MORE WELCOMING TO
ALL THE IDENTITIES ARE OUT
THERE AND AS A BISEXUAL THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY I'M MORE
TECHNICALLY AND WERE OFFICIALLY
WOULD BE PANSEXUAL IS I'D
REJECT THE BINARY OF THE
GENDER. OF IS. WE HAVE TO
REMIND WE HAVE. WE HAVE TO
BECAUSE THEY REMINDED THAT WE
ARE IN THE LGBT COMMIT LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY IS NOT SIMPLY AS
SOMETIMES WE STILL HEAR
RHETORIC TODAY OF SIMPLY WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE BEDROOM THAT IS
THE MOST OFFENSIVE AND
REDUCTIVE BOILING DOWN OF
IDENTITY. IS ABOUT HOW EXPRESS.
OUR LOVE OUR IDENTITY AND WHO
AND HOW WHICH IS OVER LIVE OUR
LIVES AND FOR THE FOLKS OUT
THERE. WHO ARE IN CALIFORNIA
AND IN THIS COUNTRY WHO
CONSTANTLY HAVE TO LIVE EVERY
DAY WITH BEING MISGENDERED DEAD
NAMES. OR ANY OTHER SORT OF
MICRO MACRO AGGRESSION OUT
THERE THAT EXISTS. WE ARE HERE
TO LISTEN TO YOU WE'RE HERE TO
UPLIFT TO INCLUDE YOU IN THIS
COMING KANSEI BEER THE FIGHT I
REMEMBER EVEN. YES ONLY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT MEMBERS HAVE
ASKING FOR LIKE WHEN DID I COME
OUT IS I THINK REALLY NEVER HAD
A COMING OUT THE I JUST KIND OF
EXISTED IN THAT KIND OF ROME I
THINK THAT IS GOING TO BECOME
MORE OF A TREND AND MORE OF THE
MORE OF THE- WAY THINGS ARE
DONE IN IN THE FUTURE. I
BELIEVE I READ THAT ONE IN SIX
CHEN ZEROS ARE ACTUALLY LGBT
COSTS IDENTIFYING ALREADY I
THINK THAT NUMBER WILL ONLY
GROW GROW MORE. I JUST REMEMBER
AND I THINK THIS IS THE FEELING
THAT MOST LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE NOW
IS. THE MOMENT YOU KNOW THAT
YOU DON'T FEEL LIKE YOU BELONG
WE DON'T FEEL LIKE YOU BELONG
BASED ON THE NORMS OF THE DAY
IS WHEN YOU START HAVING THAT
SENSE OF IN CLING THAT'S- YOU
PERHAPS DON'T FIT THE
HETERONORMATIVE STEREOTYPE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT I REMEMBER
MY FIRST- PARTNER THE TIME CALL
ME HETERO FLEXIBLE. IF I WAS
WITH. A WOMAN AT THE TIME SO
IT'S VERY INTERESTING SO EVEN
OTHER PEOPLE TO TELL OF AND
THIS IS AN INTERESTING TIMES
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP IT WAS
AND ALSO IT'S GREAT I WAS AND
THERE WAS A PROP EIGHT DAYS AND
THAT JUST PASSED AND THAT WAS
REALLY FORMING. THE IDENTITY OF
WHEN YOU KNOW OUR OUR STATE HAD
JUST HAD A REFERENDUM SAYING IS
GAMERS OKAY OR NOT AND IN
HINDSIGHT YOU THINK ABOUT TO
GET THIS MORNING. YOU KNOW I
THINK THE GREAT STRIDES MADE
EDUCATION AS I REMEMBER USED TO
BE- ALMOST FASHIONABLE TO SAY
SOMETHING YOU DON'T LIKE IS
GAY. I THINKING BACK ON IT LIKE
YOU KNOW DECADES OF FOUR I
THINK THAT'S SUCH A CRAZY TIME
SUCH AN ARTIFACT OF THAT TIME
BUT HOW MUCH PROGRESS WE'VE
MADE. I KNOW I'M RAMBLING A
LITTLE BIT BUT I THINK IT'S
JUST IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
EXPRESS THEMSELVES SO THEY'RE
DIFFERENTLY AND IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE RESPECT THAT
HOW THEY EXPRESS THEIR GENDER
ACCESS TO HOW THEY LOVE. AND
ESPECIALLY HAS A BISEXUAL
MEMBER YOU KNOW I ALWAYS THINK
ABOUT. DO I BELONG EVEN TO THE
LGBT COMMUNITY BECAUSE IF I DID
A WOMAN THE PEOPLE THINK I'M
STRAIGHT IF I DID A MAN THAT IF
PEOPLE THINK I'M GAY AND THAT
IS SOMETHING I'VE HEARD FROM SO
MUCH OF THE COMMUNITY THAT.
THEY FEEL THEY DON'T BELONG TO
EITHER COMMITTEE AND AS I CAME
OUT OPENLY WELL AS A LEGISLATOR
I HAVE HEARD SO MANY MEMBERS OF
MY CAN YOU SAY I'M FLAT AND
BRADLEY OF REPRESENTATION THE
STATE I'M GLAD. TO BE LEVEL
LIVE AUTHENTICALLY AS BY SOCIAL
SIX. L. AS A BISEXUAL MEMBER
COMMUNITY. SO HAPPY SO. PRIVATE
YOU. AND THANK SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MISTER LEE. DECEMBER WELL
YOUR YOUR DESK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER IN
COLLEAGUES MY PRONOUNS ARE HE
HIM AND HIS AND I PROUDLY STAND
AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS LOOK AT HOW
BEAUTIFUL THIS ROOM IT JUST
BEAMING WITH PRIDE. ING WITH
DIVERSITY. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO CELEBRATE BUT WE MUST ALSO
REMEMBER OUR HISTORY. AND AS A
LEGISLATIVE STAFFER AND AS A
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
FOR IT NOW FIFTEEN YEARS. AND
MY FIRST YEAR WORKING IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE FAMILY THERE WAS A
TIME IN WHICH PRIDE WAS
CELEBRATED ON THIS VERY FLOOR.
IN WHICH MEMBERS OF ON THE
OTHER CROSS OF THE AISLE WOULD
ALL STORM GET UP AND WALK OFF
THE FLOOR. SO TO MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
I THINK YOU WERE IN THIS ROOM.
FOR GIVING US THE DIGNITY TO
RECOGNIZE PRIDE. AT THE SAME
TIME IMAGINE. THAT YES WE HAVE
COME A LONG WAY. BUT THERE'S
STILL A GUT PUNCH THAT STILL
OCCURS REGULARLY EACH AND EVERY
YEAR. A BLOOD DRIVE WE OF
COURSE KNOW THE IMPORTANCE HERE
IN THE STATE CAPITAL OF HOSTING
A BLOOD DRIVE TO HELP SAVE
LIVES. IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE
FOR SOMEONE LIKE MYSELF. AND SO
MANY OTHERS. IN OUR COMMUNITY
M. WHICH BECAUSE THERE IS A-
BAN ON GAY MEN DONATING BLOOD
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE.
BUT THAT FEELS LIKE TO BE
REMINDED THAT. WE ARE NO GOOD.
THAT YES WE WANT TO SAVE LIVES
SACRIFICE OF OURSELVES BUT. NOT
YOUR BLOOD THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH YOU. COLLEAGUES
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE STAFFERS IN THIS
BUILDING WHO ARE NOT OUT. AND
IT'S AN INCUMBENT UPON US ALL
ALSO TO MAKE INCLUSIVE AND
WORKPLACE AND ENVIRONMENT FOR
THEM TO FEEL SAFE. AND SO THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
REFLECT THE REPRESENT. NOT ONLY
IS THE STATE CAPITAL BUT
CALIFORNIA. THAT WHERE PLACE OF
INCLUSION NOT EXCLUSION.
COLLEAGUES THERE ARE CURRENTLY
EXIST OVERALL A HUNDRED PIECES
OF PENDING LEGISLATION IN THE
COUNTRY AND MULTIPLE STATE
ATTACKING MEMBERS OF ELDER
COMMUNITY WHY. ANTI TRANS
LEGISLATION TO PREVENT KIDS
FROM BEING KIDS FROM ALLOWING
AND PREVENTING I SHOULD SAY
FROM PREVENTING INDIVIDUALS FOR
BEING WHO THEY ARE TO BE
AUTHENTIC. LET'S JUST PAUSE FOR
A MOMENT AND PUT YOUR SELF IN
THE MINDSET OF A YOUNG TRANS
PERSON. AND THE DIFFICULTY
ALREADY AS IT IS TO FIND A
PLACE OF ACCEPTANCE. AND THAT'S
WHY WE CELEBRATE PRIDE AND WE
ALSO REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT.
TO HELPING CREATE A WORKPLACE A
SOCIETY THAT IS EQUITABLE. IT
IS NOT JUST ABOUT EMPTY
RHETORIC AND ABOUT A BEAUTIFUL
BEAUTIFUL. NASCO BUT WHEN WE
TAKE OFF THAT MASK YOU WILL
LOOK IN. INSIDE THAT WE REALIZE
THAT THERE'S MUCH PAIN. SO LET
US BE A GREAT EXAMPLE NOT JUST
FOR THE NATION BUT FOR THE
WORLD AND SAYING THAT YOU
BELONG AND WE LOVE YOU TOO.
TRULY YOU BELONG. AND ASK YOU
TO SEEK OUT IN THIS MOMENT.
SOMEONE ELSE WHO PERHAPS YOU
MIGHT NOT BE AS ACCEPTING OR
LOVING OR BABY JUST NOT AS
FAMILIAR WITH THE LGBT
COMMUNITY BUT SEEK THEM OUT AND
HAVE DIALOGUE AND THAT'S HOW
WE'RE GOING TO. HELP ON THE
TRAJECTORY OF INCLUSION AND I
THINK ALL OF YOU FOR HELPING US
CELEBRATE PRIDE MONTH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK MR YOU
MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AN ASSET THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU MISTER MARTIN
IS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. PERSONAL FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE FOR ALL
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO BE HONEST
CO AUTHORS. PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE.
RIGHT CLICK CLOSER ROLE I'D
THERE ARE FIFTY FIVE CO AUTHORS.
NEXT WE'LL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
FOR ADOPTION OF THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THE
SAY NO. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
THIS YEAR MARKS THE NINETEENTH
ASSEMBLY OBSERVANCE OF THE
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER AND QUEER PLUS
PRIDE MONTH TODAY WE WILL
RECOGNIZE EXCEPTIONAL
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
ADVANCING FULL EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE FOR THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE OF THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OUR HONOREES
ARE NOT PRESENT BUT WE WOULD
WANT TO SHARE THEIR NAMES AND
SOME OF THE BIOGRAPHICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THEM WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE RECOGNITION OF
THE LGBTQ PLUS PRIDE MONTH
HONOREES FOR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE CLERK
WILL READ. OUR FIRST HONOREE AS
ROBERT GENTRY. ROBERT GENTRY
BECAME THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
MAYOR IN CALIFORNIA WHEN HE WON
AN ELECTION IN THE CITY OF
LAGUNA BEACH. OUR SECOND
HONOREE AS CONNOR MADDOX.
CONNOR MADDOX IS A TRANSGENDER
ACTIVISTS AND RECIPIENTS OF THE
HARVEY MILK SILVA RIGHTS AWARD.
OUR THIRD HONOREE IS DENNIS
SUNNY. DENNIS SONNY IS A
VETERAN WHO'S WORKED WITH
CALIFORNIA'S MANUFACTURING
NETWORK HAS LED TO NUMEROUS
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE HE IS ALSO
DEDICATED TO ADVANCING
DIVERSITY. OUR FOURTH HONOREE
IS LLOYD HOMES. DR LLOYD HOMES
IS PRESIDENT OF DE ANZA COLLEGE
IN CUPERTINO HE IS THE FIRST
OPENLY GAY BLACK MAN TO HOLD
THIS TITLE. OUR FIFTH HONOREE
IS TRUE LLOYD. YOU LORENA IS A
TECH AND LEGAL INDUSTRY
COMMUNICATIONS CONSULTANT IN
THE SILICON VALLEY AND
PRESIDENT OF BAY MAC THE OLDEST
NONPARTISAN LGBTQ PLUS
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE IN
CALIFORNIA. R. SIX HONOREE IS
GERRY MAKORI. GARY MAKORI IS
THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS
FOR HEALTH RIGHT THREE SIXTY
AND CO PRESIDENT OF THE ALICE
B. TOKLAS LGBT Q. DEMOCRATIC
CLUB. OUR SEVENTH HONOREE IS
KIM TRAN. KIM TRAN IS A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZER RESEARCHER
AND WRITER WHOSE WORK HAS
SPARKED SOCIAL CHANGE
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
ASIAN AMERICAN SOLIDARITY AND
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT.
OUR EIGHTH HONOREE IS LAYING
THEM TAU. LAYING LOOTAH IS THE
DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL RELATIONS
FOR THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN HE BECAME
THE FIRST OPENLY GAY MAN
ELECTED TO PUBLIC OFFICE IN
STOCKTON. OUR KNIFE ON A RE IS
LUIZ EL FARO. LUIS ALFARO IS AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA A PERFORMER AND A
MACARTHUR FELLOWSHIP WINNER.
ARE TENTH ON A RE IS ROBERTA
ACHTENBERG. ATTORNEY ROBERTA
ACTING BURKE MADE HISTORY IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE AS THE
FIRST OPENLY LGBT Q. PLUS
PERSON TO BE NOMINATED AND
CONFIRMED FOR A CABINET
POSITION WHEN PRESIDENT CLINTON
APPOINTED HER AS ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT FOR FAIR HOUSING.
AND EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. FOR
POSTHUMOUS RECOGNITION THE
CAUCUS ARTIST YOU WANNA RES.
THE FIRST IS GEORGE MURPHY. THE
LATE GEORGE MURPHY WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE SAN
DIEGO LGBT Q. A COMMUNITY
CENTER AND ACADEMIC COUNSELOR
AT GROSSMONT COLLEGE. THE
SECOND AND THE LAST ON A RE
TODAY IS LARRY BAZA. THE LATE
LARRY BOSSO WASN'T LGBT Q. PLUS
ACTIVISTS WHO ALSO ADVOCATED
FOR THE ARTS AND GREATER ACCESS
TO EDUCATION IN SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU WE WANT TO
CONGRATULATE ALL OF OUR
HONREES IT'S THROUGH THEIR
ENDEAVORS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
MADE HISTORY ON LGBTQ PROGRESS
SERVING AS AN INSPIRATION TO
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY. AND
ALTHOUGH WE REGRET IN THESE
TIMES THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
JOIN US HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS THIS YEAR WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS
ABOUT OUR FORUM OURS ZOOM-
PRESENTATIONS THAT WILL BE
OCCURRING THIS THURSDAY. AT SIX
PM- WITH THE LGBTQ CAUCUS IF
YOU'RE A MEMBER IS NOT
AVAILABLE WE CAN DISCUSS A PRE
RECORDED MESSAGE HONOREES WILL
BE LIVE ON THE SOON AS WELL AND
IF YOU'D LIKE MORE INFORMATION
PLEASE VISIT OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS TO BE ABLE TO WITNESS
THAT- BLIVE. THURSDAY AT SIX PM
LET'S GIVE ALL OF OUR
CONGRATULATIONS TO OUR HONOREES
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU MEMBERS
THIS CONCLUDES OUR OBSERVANCE.
WHEN I MOVED TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE SECOND READING.
CORKERY SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY
EIGHTEEN WITH A MINUTE SEVEN
FIFTY SIX OF THE MEMBERS FIVE
FIFTY TWO WITH A MINUTE SIX
TWENTY FOUR WITH A MOMENT SEVEN
OH EIGHT EIGHT TWENTY TWO WITH
A MEMBERS THIRTY NINE FOR THE
MINUTES AND SENATE BILL FIFTY
EIGHT WITH A MINUTES. ALL BILLS
WILL BE DEEMED READ OMINOUS
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. MOVING
ON TO CONCURRENCE AND
SENTIMENTS WITH FILE ITEM. TEN
THIS GONZALEZ WHO RECOGNIZED.
ACCORDING ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS INOCULATING
THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION AND
DECLARE THE URGENCY THERE UP
THE CORRECT IMMEDIATELY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OF COURSE
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE FROM THE
SENATE IT WOULD EMPOWER
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WITH A VARIETY OF CHOICES THAT
HOLD STATES HARMLESS FOR THE
ISSUES THEY FACE THIS PAST YEAR
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO
PETITION FOR GRADE RETENTION
PURSUE CREDIT RECOVERY
OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND A FORTY
YEAR HIGH SCHOOL AND TO REQUEST
A PASS NO PASS OPTION FOR
GRADES ATTAINTED DURING THIS
PAST ACADEMIC YEAR. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT IT'S AN
URGENCY MEASURE I'M HOPEFUL
THAT YOU WILL VOTE FOR IT TODAY
SEND IT TO THE GOVERNOR AND
ASKED HIM TO QUICKLY ACT ON
THIS SINCE SCHOOL IS MAINLY OUT
AND WE NEED TO PREPARE FR NEXT
YEAR FOR STUDENTS THANK YOU
THANKS GONZALEZ SEEING NO
MEMBERS WISHING TO PAINT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. SUNKEN
CURRENTS AND SENTIMENTS ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. A CLOSE ROLE. I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY. HI
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ON
CONCURRENCE AND AMENDMENTS THE
CLERK WILL PROCEED WITH THE
MEDIA TRANSMITTAL TO THE
GOVERNOR WITHOUT ANY OBJECTION.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ELEVEN AND TWELVE FOR
MOTIONS TO RECONSIDER WILL PASS
RETAIN ON ITEMS THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON ITEMS FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN MOVE INTO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN. SIMILAR
MCCARTY- DIFFICULT READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY RELATIVE TO REFUGEES
SUMMER MCCARTY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I THIS WEEKEND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND IT AND AROUND
THE GLOBE. WE CELEBRATE WORLD
REFUGEE DAY. GLOBAL EVENT
RECOGNIZED BY THE U. N.
HONORING THOSE WHO HAD FLED FOR
THEIR LIVES FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES. DONNELLY IN OUR
COUNTRY- I. WOMEN AND CHILDREN
THERE ARE OVER EIGHTY MILLION
PEOPLE DISPLACED WORLDWIDE
TWENTY SIX MILLION REFUGEES IN
THE MID. TWO THOUSANDS LATEST
COUNTS AND AGAIN 40% OF THESE
OUR CHILDREN ARE LACKING THE
BASIC NECESSITIES SUCH AS
EDUCATION- CERTAINLY AMERICA
HAS SEEN THIS LOUD AND CLEAR OF
THE DECADES AFTER THE VIETNAM
WAR AFTER THE- AFTER AFTER THE-
EFFORTS IN THE IN THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN REGION LATER
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ CALIFORNIA
IS NO STRANGER TO BEING THE
HOST FOR REFUGEE COMMUNITIES.
I'M PROUD THAT THE TOP CITIES
IN THE IN THE STATE ARE LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO THE NUMBER
ONE RESETTLEMENT CITY FOR MANY
YEARS HAS BEEN RIGHT HERE IN
THE CAPITAL CITY OF SACRAMENTO.
AS YOU ARE FIFTEEN REFLECTS
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
COURAGEOUSLY FLED THEIR
COUNTRIES AND I'M ALSO
RECOGNIZES OUR COUNTRY
COMMUNITIES FROM FOR WELCOMING
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO OUR REGION
I PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE AG ARE FIFTEEN
RECOGNIZING JUNE TWENTIETH
TWENTY FIRST AS WORLD. REFUGEE
DAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MCCARTY SENIOR MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS MEASURE-
MISTER KEARNEY WOULD YOU LIKE
THE FIRST RULE OF MERKEL
AUTHORS. SERVIETTE COOK OVER
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON ITEM. SEVENTEEN
ALL MEMBERS NOTED IF YOU'D LIKE
TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN. FOR JOSE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS. THE OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION. WAIT WE NEED TO DO
A ROLL CALL THOUGH BECAUSE THE
JOINT RESOLUTION SO CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THE
DESIRE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. SEVERAL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION
IS PASSED. A PASS AND RETAIN ON
ITEMS NUMBER EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN I AND NUMBER TWENTY IS
DISPENSED WITH WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON SENATE BILL THIRD
READING ITEMS. TWENTY ONE THREE
TWENTY NINE. MOVING TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTEEN
SIXTY FIVE OTHER COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT MANAGEMENT
AND ACCOLADES EMERGENCY
SERVICES DECLARING YOUR XEROX
SIGNIFICANTLY. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. LOCAL CLOSE
RULE IN TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
NINE KNOWS OR ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. AND
THERE'S ALSO AN EYE OUT THE
URGENCY I. SIXTY NINE TWO ZERO.
LOCAL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. JUST.
ONE MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. BEFORE THE ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY THERE'S A BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENT THERE WILL BE A
GROUP PHOTO. RIGHT AFTER A
GERMAN TODAY FOR THOSE WISHING
TO BE ABLE TO CELEBRATE PRIDE
CEREMONIES HERE TODAY AS WELL
THAT WILL BE AT THE FRONT OF
THE CHAMBERS. WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. SO I
ASK THAT YOU TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
OR PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
ALREADY INCLUDE.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY WE ASK YOU TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR OR
JOIN US AT YOUR DESK. A FEW
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY SPEAKER
RENDON YOU'RE RECOGNIZING HER
DESK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK
THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF HOWARD CHAMBERS.
HOWEVER CHAMBERS IS A LEGEND IN
MY DISTRICT HAVING SERVED AS
CITY MANAGER THE CITY OF
LAKEWOOD FOR FORTY ONE YEARS WE
BELIEVE THAT IS LONGER THAN ANY
OTHER CITY MANAGER HAS SERVED
IN ANYONE CITY. POWER DIED FROM
CANCER ON JUNE NINTH AT HIS
HOME IN BREA HE PASSED AWAY AT
HOME SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY.
WHEN HE WAS IN HIS LAST DAYS I
SENT IN A VIDEO GREETING
BECAUSE HIS WORK MEANT SO MUCH
TO SO MANY PEOPLE. HE WAS THE
CITY MANAGER OF LAKE WOULD BUT
HE WAS ALSO A PRODUCT OF THE
CITY. HE WAS BORN IN LAKEWOOD
IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR BEFORE
IT WAS EVEN CORPORATIONS THE
CITY. HE WAS THERE AT THE
BEGINNING AND HE WAS THERE FOR
LAKE WOULD IN MANY MANY WAYS.
SOMETIMES IT WAS USING HIS LONG
VISION TO GET ALL THE STREETS
RESURFACED OVER SEVERAL YEARS
SOMETIMES IT WAS THIS PRACTICAL
APPROACH IN NEGOTIATING
AGREEMENTS WITH LONG BEACH IS
BIGGER NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR.
HOWARD FINALLY LEFT HIS
POSITION AS CITY MANAGER IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. BUT HIS
INFLUENCE CONTINUED. WE'RE
SORRY TO HAVE LOST HIS PRESENCE
THIS MONTH. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE MARY A BROTHER JIM. A
SON TODD TAYLOR. HIS DAUGHTER
SHADIAN SAMANTHA. AND HIS
GRANDDAUGHTER LOLA MOXIE MORROW
I ASKED AT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED TODAY THE MEMORY. OF
THIS LOCAL LEADER AND LEGEND
THANK YOU MISTER BAKER. THANK
YOU SPEAKER RENDON. SENATOR
PRIYANKA RECOGNIZE YOUR
DESPERATE GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF SANDRA THAT HONESTY
WILL A COMMUNITY LEADER THAT
DEDICATED HER LIFE TO UP
LIFTING LATINO LEADERSHIP AND
SERVING FAMILIES IN EAST LOS
ANGELES. MANY OF US WHO KNEW
HER LOVINGLY CALLED HER SANDY
SANDY WAS BORN IN OHIO AND
MOVED TO LOS ANGELES AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN SHE WAS A VOLUNTEER
ON BOBBY KENNEDY'S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT WHERE SHE MET HER HUSBAND
MATEO AT A MEETING OF THE PEACE
AND FREEDOM PARTY AND MARRIED
IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. SHE
WENT ON TO LEAD THE CAMPAIGN
FOR THE FIRST LEVINE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAME A MENTOR TO
MANY FUTURE LATINO LEADERS AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS MYSELF
INCLUDED WHEN I WAS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE SHE CALLED ME AND SAID
SHE WANTED TO MEET AT A
RESTAURANT IN EAST LOS ANGELES
A POPULAR PLACE FOR LOCAL
ELECTED LEADERS AND TO BE
HONEST I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS.
BUT SHE MADE ME FEEL
IMMEDIATELY AT EASE SHE SHARED
POLITICAL STORIES SHE SAID TO
ME ALL ME HEAT THAT I KNOW ALL
THE CHEESE MAN. THEN SHE
LAUGHED HER EYES SPARKLING WITH
INSIGHT. AND HER BIG SMILE
MAKING ME FEEL WELCOMED INTO
HER WORLD OF INSIGHT. BUT HER
HEART AND HER LIFE'S PASSION
PROJECT WITHOUT A CENTRAL THE
NINO THE BILINGUAL CHILD
DEVELOPMENT CENTER THAT SHE
FOUND IT AND WHERE SHE SERVED
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
ALMOST FIFTY YEARS. AS CENTER
THE NINO HAS BECOME HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED AS AN INNOVATIVE AND
AWARD WINNING CHILD DEVELOPMENT
CURRICULUM FOR THE UNDERSERVED
FAMILIES OF EAST LOS ANGELES IN
FACT SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO RETIRE
IN TWENTY TWENTY. BUT BECAUSE
OF COVERT NINETEEN. SHE STAYED
ON TO CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR
BEAUTIFUL COMMUNITY OF EAST LA
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT SO MANY OF
OUR ESSENTIAL WORKERS AT SCHOOL
SWITCHED TO DISTANCE LEARNING
AND WHILE SO MANY FAMILIES NEED
A CHILD CARE AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE. FOR THIS AND FOR
MANY OTHER REASONS I WAS HONOR
TO RECOGNIZE HER WORK AT A
CENTRAL THE NINO THAT'S OUR
TWENTY TWENTY NONPROFIT OF THE
YEAR AMID THE PANDEMIC. I WAS
SO PROUD TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
DONE THAT BEFORE SHE LEFT US.
IS THE LAST TIME THAT I
ACTUALLY SAW HER IN PERSON.
SANDY WILL BE REMEMBERED AS A
MENTOR TO LET THE NOT THE
CHAMPION FOR CHILDREN IN A
DEDICATED LEADER WHO EMPOWER
THOSE AROUND HER. SHE WILL READ
BE REMEMBERED FOR HER
UNWAVERING DEDICATION TO THE UN
REPRESENTATIVE FAMILIES OF EAST
LA. AND SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
AND HER GENEROUS SPIRIT. TO HER
FRIENDS AND HER FAMILY. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY MARIO HER SPOUSE OF
FIFTY ONE YEARS. HER SON DAVID.
HER DAUGHTER NICOLE. AND HER
GRANDCHILDREN. I AM THANKFUL TO
HER. HER DEDICATION TO
UPLIFTING OTHERS AND HER
IMPACT. ON GENERATIONS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE RAISED IN EAST LOS
ANGELES. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AND I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF SANDRA. SAIDI
DON'T SEE WELL. SANDY A
POWERFUL. UNAPOLOGETIC FEARS
SHE GONNA FROM THE EAST SIDE.
AND OUR COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY. AND SERVICE MAY SHE
REST IN POWER THANK YOU. THANK
MISCREANT. SIMILAR RUBIO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR DESK
YOUR FIRST ADJOURNMENT MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
JOIN IN MEMORY OF HELEN JEAN
MCMULLEN FERGUSON. A LONGTIME
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE AND RESIDENT
OF THE FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. HELEN AND HER HUSBAND
AT THE IMPACT IN THE FORTY
EIGHT IS FAR REACHING AND SPANS
DECADES. AS A MEMBER OF THE
MONROVIA GUILD OF CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL VALET THE TORTILLA
DUCATION FOUNDATION PRESIDENT
OF THE CITRUS COLLEGE
FOUNDATION AND LECTOR AT IMPA
MACULAR CONCEPTION CHURCH. FOR
COMMUNITY SERVICE HAS IMPACTED
COUNTLESS RESIDENTS OF OUR
DISTRICT. IN ADDITION TO HER
LEADERSHIP IN EXISTING
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS. HELEN AND
ED ESTABLISH THE FERGUSON
EDUCATION FOUNDATION OVER
SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO TO SUPPORT
THE EDUCATIONAL ASPIRATIONS OF
DARTY RESIDENTS STUDENTS
LOOKING TO ATTEND COLLEGE.
SINCE ITS ESTABLISHMENT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
AWARDED TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY LOOKING TO FURTHER
THEIR EDUCATION. AND HER TIME
OUTSIDE OF VOLUNTEERING HELEN
HAVE A PASSION TO TRAVEL TO
EXPERIENCE DIFFERENT COUNTRIES
AND CULTURES. HELEN ANN ED
SPENT PORTIONS OF THEIR SIXTY
NINE YEARS TOGETHER EXPLORING
THE WORLD TOGETHER HOWEVER HER
TRUE JOY CAME FROM WATCHING HER
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN GROW
TOGETHER. HELEN I SURVIVED BY
HER CHILDREN JIM MARGARET HELEN
AND ED ALONG WITH SIXTEEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND THIRTY TWO
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. HELEN
BROCK GREAT SUPPORT TO THE
COMMUNITY THE TO THE COMMUNITY
OF THE FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF HELEN
JEAN MCMILLAN FERGUSON. THANK
YOU MISTER RUBIO YOU'RE GONNA
RECOGNIZE YOUR DESK FOR YOUR
SECOND ADJOURNMENT MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. TODAY I REQUEST WITH
DURING THE MEMORY OF LORRAINE
CHRISTIE KRYSTLE A RESIDENT AND
ADVOCATE OF THE FOURTEENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. LORRAINE WAS A
MEMBER OF VARIOUS COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING ADDRESS
DUARTE PTA STARTETE WOMAN'S
CLUB AND THE CITY OF DARTY
PLANNING COMMISSION LORRAINE
HAS DEMONSTRATED DECADES WORTH
OF COMMUNITY SERVICE AND
ADVOCACY. SHE WAS ALSO A DEVOUT
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY PARISH
PROVIDING SUPPORT VIA FOOD
DRIVES AND CLOTHING DRIVES
AMONG THE VARIOUS OTHER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS ESTABLISHED IN OUR
COMMUNITY. SHE WAS AN AVID
ARTIST AND PARTICIPANT IN LOCAL
ART SHOWS AND EXPOSITIONS AT
WHICH HER TALENTS WERE
RECOGNIZED WITH SEVERAL
OUTSTANDING AWARDS FOR HER OIL
AND WATERCOLOR PAINTINGS. HER
WORK HER WORKS ARE PRESENT IN
THE ROOMS OF COUNTLESS FAMILY
MEMBERS FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATES WHICH SERVE AS ARM
REMINDERS OF LORRAINE'S KIND
AND GIVING SPIRIT. THIS
COMMUNITY CHERISHED SO MUCH.
LORRAINE IS SURVIVED BY HER
DAUGHTERS SHARON AND AUDREY AS
WELL AS HER GRANDCHILDREN
NIECES AND NEPHEWS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE JOINED
IN MEMORY OF ONE OF THE
FOURTEENTH FINANCE MEMBERS
LORRAINE CRYSTAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
THE MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINT IN THE JOURNAL.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS AGAIN
MEMBERS THERE WILL BE A GROUP
PHOTO IMMEDIATELY UPON
ADJOURNMENT FOR ALL MEMBERS WHO
WISH TO JOIN THE LGBT CAUCUS IN
HONOR OF PRIDE MONTH. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JUNE TWENTY SECOND
CHECK IN SESSION. WEDNESDAY
JUNE TWENTY THIRD CHECK IN
SESSION. THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY
FOURTH FLOOR SESSION AT NINE
AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
ON THE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO BUSINESS FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY MAKES A MOTION TO
MR COOLEY SECONDS OF THIS HOUSE
STANDARD CHURN. UNTIL THURSDAY
JUNE TWENTY FOURTH AT NINE AM
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED.